[Music] hand speeding when you're ready heads
up this is turning into quite a mess
I'm Mark Stone from the Vegas golden
knights Stone flakes St the silver trophy
to the golden lights and I'm going to break
stuff growing up you remember breaking anything
the only thing I can really remember is breaking
my uh neighbor's tail light that was a bit
of a tough one to to tell dad hit them both
I'll probably miss him [Music] though
whoops I didn't hit anything kind of
[Music]
embarrassing little stressful missing
the missing the targ the first time
but when you see it [Applause] explode
definitely makes you feel pretty [Music]
[Music] good this is turning into quite a
[Music] mess
did a pretty good job getting most of
[Music]
it finish it
off pretty satisfying
feeling
what